I'm joined by the Conservative MP
indicud Smith and the Labour MP is
Stella Creasy
now mr. Duncan Smith to you first is a
staunch leaver what would you say to
people in Bristol who are clearly
worried about what happens when the UK
leaves the EU well that's all part of
the process that takes place you invoke
article 50 you can't do anything until
then but you then get on to discuss with
the European Union about what happens
next I mean truth is in the European
Union's quite divided about all this at
the moment I mean you've got what are
the nations represented at the council
and then you've got the Commission the
Commission has tended to play a fairly
rhetorical hardline actually the nations
are in a slightly different position you
know I talked a lot to various members
of governments now in the last sort of
four or five months and they're they're
developing a line along lines we must
make some kind of agreement or
settlement the Commission has been
saying no so what you're actually seeing
is the beginnings of a clash between the
two and who runs it was quite a scene
the other day Donald Tusk who's heads up
basically the council he was both very
positive about the future role for the
UK both regards to the USA and also
internally but also there now they're on
the defining terms so they've put
themselves in and they will define the
terms and therefore that is good for us
means they'll be looking for some kind
of arrangement after are you quite so
positive about all this or I think what
we're seeing with brexit is that you can
either do it quickly or you can do it
well and what I want is the best deal
for our country
Ian says all look it's all great and
roses are coming up in Europe but
actually we know in Europe right now
there are lots and lots of difficult
issues happening we know there are
elections in France we know there are
elections in Holland we know they're
going to be elections in Germany one of
the concerns I have is the government is
so determined to press ahead with brexit
and a hard brexit that they want to
trigger in March when a lot of these
countries that we might want to be
negotiating with will have rightly one
eye on their domestic political
situation rather than both eyes on what
the future role for Europe can be so one
of the things a lot of us are trying to
say is more haste less fee and you of
course try to stop the article 50
process you voted against it I mean even
the people I spoke to in Bristol seem to
be accepting that we are going to leave
the EU are you not accepting that made
no mistake we are leaving the European
Union but the bill that's going through
Parliament right now is about how we
leave the European Union with
we green likely approach that the Prime
Minister is taking and the people in
your film are talking rightly about
their concerns about red tape about the
fact that we will see a very changed
economic position you know that man
who's trying to trade skateboards I
never thought I'd be arguing with
conservative governments about bringing
in more red tape but that exactly what
their approach is going to do they're
talking about leaving not just a single
market but the customs union and the
common commercial policy for a kind of
membership that doesn't even exist and I
think that gentlemen deserves the
honesty and the decency of a proper plan
and a proper approach to these
negotiations that doesn't put his
business at risk in the way this
government is doing at the moment of
course the government's invoked leaving
without a deal at all if we don't get a
good deal that would mean huge tariffs
on things like cars clothes
that's not understand what the World
Trade Organization also governs what the
European Union does people think that
they're somehow exempt from it they're
not the World Trade organization's rules
and schedules govern what the EU does
even governs their arrangements with
other nations so you have a set of rules
if you'll subscribe to where a member of
the WTO so those rules govern maximums
that you can do so they're not where
tariffs go so even if we didn't have an
agreement as it were at the time you can
have an agreement within the WTO rules
that allow you to say at the moment we
don't have any tariffs in the single
market but on WTO rule in some others
however my point is that about the
second place there are plenty of other
countries that operate zero tariffs or
regimes in the WTO so the key question
here is what is the arrangement now the
government has said quite clearly what
they want to have they want to arrange
is to have a proper arrangement based on
the idea of free trade between us after
all that shouldn't be too difficult
because we are a member of the European
Union therefore all of our rules and
regulations correspond exactly the
European Union the second part of it is
even under the World Trade Organization
there because I think we're trade
organization rules you can go to zero
tariffs and have free access on seven
governed by gian but in there has to be
some honesty here for men like that
businessman that actually we can't just
fall back on World Trade Organization
rules because the World Trade
Organization in let me finish the rules
that we currently have reflect the
relationship we have with the European
Union so even if we leave without a deal
and we fall back on World Trade
Organization rules they won't be the
same rules because they're dependent
órale
a ship with Europe we have total honesty
in this debate it's a bit like standing
in front of a bus fetching 350 million
pounds the NHS and then saying so we're
not gonna be able to deliver at work
you've admitted and I'll admit the rules
to admit this so don't think all of our
relationship with the World Trade
Organization is dependent our
relationship with Europe isn't it so
when we leave the European Union our
relationship with the World Trade
Organization will also change won't it
I'll wrote a relationship with the WTO
is we are not a voting member at the
moment we are a member we become a
voting member now that actually our our
tariffs for the World Trade Organization
dependent on being part of the European
Union yes on European Union they know
the European Union deal is a customs
unit inside that border you set the same
tariffs for external trade are on your
tariffs with the World Trade
Organization at the moment dependent on
also being part of the European League
we have a deal with the European Union
as a member right leave the World Trade
Organization
you said you agree and accept we're
leaving if we're leaving then that means
leaving that organization you know
they're not going to want us to stay in
the single market because you have to
come under European law and you have to
accept the common tariffs we're not
going to do that because the one to six
so the question we're facing now my man
in that film is giving free lowest
amount in the waiver at the factory I
have a kind of sense that you're not
going to agree no this particular issue
how about Parliament having a say or
more of a say than its had already the
whole point of the referendum campaign
or a big point of it was all about
parliamentary sovereignty so surely you
must welcome Parliament having more
scrutiny yeah there'll be tons of
scrutiny there are two elements to this
the first is that the government will
continually come back they've committed
to that the second thing is that they're
going to have another bill called the
repeal of the 1972 European Union
communities Act that has everything to
do with the European Union arrangements
that I'm sure that Labour Party or
whatever will amend it will have endless
debate endless votes we have to get that
through and repeal it before we can
actually leave the European Union so
this huge amount of debate yet to come
the government will be held to account
endlessly right and of course no part of
this debate of course will be about
integration labour is really in a bit of
a difficult position on immigration
isn't it Stella Creasy
Diane Abbott of course didn't turn out
too
on article 50 were you disappointed
we're MPs like myself had to make a very
difficult decision about whether or
today for article 50 not to see her
going for one of the voting lobbies look
for a lot of us I mean the fact that
we've only had five days allocated for
some hugely complicated decisions and
some difficult choices for say the
people in your film I just think is
completely unacceptable I mean you had
you know thirty days when you were
looking at the Maastricht Treaty five
days isn't good enough so each of us had
to make a decision about whether the
process as well as the purpose of this
bill was considered good enough to get
that best deal for Britain now I made a
decision I actually frankly think this
is bigger than any fiscal party you know
it is about whether you think we're
likely to get the best deal for Britain
I go back to this question again just
some honesty of people the government's
had to be pulled kicking and screaming
to getting Parliament into this process
the Prime Minister spent seven months
just saying brexit means brexit means
breakfast means breakfast you know
no wonder that gentleman in Bristol is
really really worried same again on this
issue about whether it's EU Nationals
whether it's about the role of
parliament in the deal or even as a
saying you stood in front of those buses
saying we'll get 350 million pounds for
the NHS great design mean you're going
to be backing our amendment amendment
number 11 well I think to that certain
point I know then help your back or
amendment look at it but my point is
that's proper politics but this is this
is up to the government to the end of
day the money is there it wouldn't be
there if you were still in the European
Union which you guys voted to remain in
you wouldn't even be able to get that
money back so this debate only begins
about where you place the money we get
back as to where that goes exactly EU
nationals I've always been in favor so
great does that mean you'll all be
backing our amendment listen these
amendments are not relevant really for
one good reason this bill is solely
about one limited purpose gives the part
of the government to invoke article 50
after that you'll have plenty of time
you have a point of the European
immunities repeal Act which you can
amend to help this and that'll have the
debate there will be more debates in the
public alert sick and tired of the
debates let me tell you something about
the house government people we've fed up
with these programs and apparently I've
already put it up with them this is our
only opportunity to start the
negotiations right to get the best deal
for Britain so absolutely it matters how
we amend this legislation absolutely
matters that the government is trying in
a hundred and sixty seven words to take
away so many fundamental
for the British people without proper so
a Stella Stella did you vote for the
referendum act at all about when we have
we said we said that we should have the
reference the referendum Kirsten that
doesn't mean what we're going to
greenlight yeah but your show you
absolutely right when you voted for that
referendum right voted to give the part
of the British people to say yes thank
you very much for coming on the show
very lively discussion there between in
Duncan Smith and Stella Creasy thank